Since around 2008 when the DSLR
revolution full frame sensors in the
hands of amateur filmmakers and
videographers,
super shallow depth of field has become
something of a cliche in indie
filmmaking.
For a lot of filmmakers,
myself included.
This effect was used not just as a tool
but as a crutch to achieve that
cinematic look.
These days,
super shallow focus is everywhere.
It's a fashion more than a technique,
so it's really,
really cool to see an episodic show like
the handmaid's tale,
incorporate the effect in a systematic
way as a motif of its visual language
and the director of the first three
episodes of the show,
the director who set the tone is Reed
Morano,
a former cinematographer.
She in her own DP for this project,
Colin Watkinson created an extremely
concentrated aesthetic one that is
beautiful and terrifying at the same
time.
To capture the dystopian world of
Gilliad meant choosing the right camera
and the right lenses.
Marano shot on the Arri Alexa Minis in
four K and use lenses that open all the
way up to apertures of one point three
and one point four,
which means your depth of field is going
to be razor thin and everything outside
of that field is going to be blown out
in a pretty uniform blur.
This shallow focus serves the story in
three ways.
First,
to capture the main character's point of
view offered played by Elizabeth Moss is
a handmade in the republic of Gilead,
a theocratic and totalitarian state that
has overtaken America in which women no
longer have any rights.
Handmaids are the last woman who can
still have children.
The rest of society being largely
sterile and they're forced to bear
children for leaders of the regime,
but it wasn't always like this before
the revolution off.
Fred lived in the America of our time,
and the story of the handmaid's tale is
really the story of the transition
between America and Gilliad told through
the experience of offered to die.
Listen to that horror read in Watkinson,
focus on the face.
It's hard to remember a show that relied
so much on one extreme closeup,
but Elizabeth Moss is definitely up to
the task with a camera mere inches from
her nose.
The filmmakers combined a wide 28
millimeter Zeiss Lens,
used only for these shots with a shallow
depth of field to create intense
intimacy with her bonnet on.
It's almost as if we're under a blanket
with a character.
The shallow depth of field extreme
closeups are an effective way to get the
audience to identify with,
offer it,
but they also point to an important
theme that as a slave in an
authoritarian state,
where your physical being is effectively
controlled by someone else,
you're only agency is mental.
The mind is where you have to retreat to
escape,
to plan,
and to remember.
It's only a thin plane of focus,
but it's still yours.
Second,
shallow focus is used to help create the
world of Gilead.
Unlike many dystopias you see in film
and TV,
Giliad is not a post apocalyptic world
of rubble and ruin.
It's actually the opposite and
meticulously manicured New England full
of sunlight and green foliage reading
Watkinson site.
Kubrick as an inspiration and they echo
a lot of his one point perspective
framings and definitely capture the
creepiness of that,
but for the women of Gilliad,
what's notable about this world is how
little they know about it.
Think of all the knowledge that's
accessible to you through the Internet
and Gilly ad.
Women are not only prohibited from going
online,
they're prohibited from reading.
Anything.
Result is a perspective that's
extraordinarily narrow and shallow.
Depth of field captures this perfectly
because it literally narrows the visual
information in Focus.
The handmaid's tale is constructed in
fragments.
You have America and you have Gilliad,
and the show gives you pieces in between
the two,
but never the full timeline.
This is in part because the show's
primary characters don't have the full
timeline themselves,
this brutal new world,
or at least the conditions that made it
possible snuck up on them.
I have to let you go,
but that doesn't mean it came out of
nowhere that they aren't somehow
connected.
For example,
even though reading Watkinson adopted
more handheld verite style for the
flashbacks,
the shallow focus remains and they do
this.
I think to suggest that both worlds
suffer from problems of limited
perspective in Gilead perspective is
limited by force,
but in our world perspective is limited
by choice.
We keep our heads down,
eyes glued to our screens,
stuck in our echo chambers.
While the blurry world around us
changes.
It brings home a vital message that our
rights are not guaranteed by the world.
We fight for them and have to protect
them everyday because it can be taken
away from us if we don't pay attention
to the world.
Beyond our focus.
Everyone likes shallow depth of field.
It's beautiful and because it's
beautiful,
everyone uses it to make their work look
better,
more professional,
more cinematic,
and as a result,
we get used to seeing it.
When I watch the handmaid's tale,
I was amazed at how much the depth of
field influence my feelings about the
characters and the world and the story.
It's just rare that you see this device
used with such purpose,
so methodically and so effectively,
and it really is effective.
If you don't believe me,
binge watch a few episodes of the
handmaid's tale than go outside at
guarantee.
You'll have a new found respect for how
much there is to see.
One of the questions I
get asked the most is what software I
use to make these videos to edit.
I use final cut pro 10 and since 10 is
so different from the version of the
program that came before it.
I depended a lot on online videos to
teach me the new features that these
days you can pretty much teach yourself
anything this way and skillshare is the
perfect way to do it at skillshare is an
online learning community for with more
than 16,000
classes in editing and graphic design,
animation,
web development,
and more.
All the classes are professional and
understandable and follow a clear
learning curve.
A premium membership begins around $10 a
month for unlimited access to all the
courses,
but the first 500 people to sign up
using the first link in the description,
we'll get a two month free trial.
In those two months.
You could easily learn the skills you
need to start a new hobby or business.
You could learn editing or even
something more specialized like after
effects,
which I always say we'll be in demand
forever.
You'll always have a job and skillshare
has dozens of classes and after effects
that can help you master that program.
What's the skill that you've been
putting off learning?
Why not sign up to skillshare it using
the link below and start right now?
Thanks guys.
I'll see you all next time.